but here okay here's the complicated
thing though
like you could think about in your own
life starting the podcast as one of
these just
cool opportunities that you put on
yourself right yeah like you know i
could have been talking to you at mit
four years ago
and like don't do that like your
research is going well right but then
everyone who watches you is like okay
this podcast is
the direction that's taking you is like
a couple years from now
it's gonna it'll be something really
monumental that you're probably just
gonna probably lead to right there'll be
some
really it just feels like your life is
going somewhere it's going somewhere
it's interesting yeah
unexpected yeah yeah so how do you
balance those two things and
so what i try to throw at it is this
this motto of do less do better know why
right so do do less
do better know why it used to be the
motto of my website years ago
um so do a few things but like an
interesting array right so i was doing
mit stuff but i was also writing you
know
so a couple things are you know they
were interesting like have a couple bets
placed on a couple different numbers on
the roulette table
but not too many things and then really
try to do those things really well and
and see where it goes like with my
writing i just spent years and years and
years just training i want to be a
better writer i want to be a better
writer i started writing student books
when i was a student
i really wanted to write hardcover idea
books i started training i would
i would use like new yorker articles to
train myself i'd break them down and i'd
get commissions with much smaller
magazines and practice the skills and
and it took forever until you know but
now today like i actually get to write
for the new yorker but it took
like a decade so a small number of
things try to do them really well and
then the know why
is have a connection to some sort of
value like in general i think
this is worth doing uh and then seeing
where it leads
and so uh the choice of the few things
is grounded in what like a little like a
like a little flame of passion like a
love for the thing like a sense that you
say you wanted to write
and get good at writing you had that
kind of
introspective moment of thinking this
actually brings me a lot of joy
and fulfillment yeah i mean it gets
complicated because i wrote a whole book
about
following your passion being bad advice
which is like the first thing i kind of
got infamous for i wrote that back in
2012.
but but the argument there is like
passion cultivates right
so what i was pushing back on was to
myth that the passion for what you do
exists full intensity before you start
and then that's what propels you
or actually the reality is as you get
better at something as you gain more
autonomy more skill and more impact the
passion grows along with it so that when
people
look back later and say oh follow your
passion what they really mean is i'm
very passionate about what i do and
that's a worthy goal
but how you actually cultivate that is
much more complicated than just
introspection is going to identify
like for sure you should be a writer or
something like this
you